our vision at the origin is millions of
people ultimately to be living and
working in space that obviously is not
happening tomorrow
and our motto at Gorgon is something
it's gradum for asar which in Latin
means step by step ferociously and
that's how we're going to approach it
and our first step by Blue Origin is a
suborbital rocket called new shepherd
named after Alan Shepard of course the
first American in suborbital space and
by the end of this year we are going to
be putting a tourists onboard new
Shepard people like you and me are going
to be going up in space
initially we know you're gonna get three
to four minutes of weightlessness so
maybe not quite orbiting the Earth or
the moon for that matter yet but our
next plan is new Glenn a big orbital
rocket that's set to fly in 2021
that it's going to be human rated and
ultimately we will be taking people to
two space stations to the moon to Mars
you know we're really a destination
agnostic if you will but ultimately we
will be taking many many people to the -
space
[Music]